what is the correct time to give your
Zakaat and fitra the calculator is
mandatory for anyone who lives after the
sunset after the month of ramadhan ends
that means if a person dies few seconds
after sunset after the month of ramadhan
ends that means the first day of shawol
that tebow visited it becomes mandatory
that hey they should give the catheter
but if a person dies few seconds before
sunset of the last day of Ramadan before
the ease of it will fitted then zakat is
not mandatory on this similarly if a
person is born a newborn child is born
before sunset on the last day of Ramadan
before the eve of fiddle sitter then
it's mandatory that the card should be
given on that newborn also but if he is
born a few seconds after sunset he has
not lived for even a second of the month
of Ramadan he's born after the sunset of
the month of Allah then the card old
feather is not further on him the best
time to give Zakaat and fitra is in the
morning before the eats Allah on the day
of fiddle fit but it can be given even
on the eve of Eid it can be given a
couple of days in the last days of
Ramadan based on the hadith but the
Prophet was very clear a beloved
portland's lustrum said it's mentioned
in so no number doubt one will be - in
the before saccade hadith number one
thing zero five the Prophet said that if
zakat is fitted it's given before the
Eid Salah of Idul Fitri is counted as a
cut if it is given after the Salaf it
wither it is counted as a trinomial
charity so it's very clear that the god
feather should be given before the Idul
Fitri salah it further mentioned in the
hadith of psy Buhari one number two in
the bahasa hat
hadith number one five zero three the
beloved person merciless room said that
give one saw of date or one saw of
barley as a rattle feather for every
Muslim for your slave young or old male
or female and it should be given before
the pee
we'll go for the axilla that means it
reduce the people who are required
should each the recipient recede before
they go out for the axilla the same
message repeated in say Muslim world
number two in the book of zakat indeed
number two one five nine the beloved
prophet said that give the cart will
filter to the people before they go for
the eat Salah
so the right ruling is that it should be
given before they eat Salah on the
ill-fated day in the morning or it can
even be given on the Eid eve but the
other hadith we say that it can be given
in the last couple of days affirmed on
information inside Buhari or in b2 in
the book of zakat height number one five
one one it says that people gave the
cattle fitter one or two days before
either
and also mentioned is a hadith of no
hazama that one person asked when did in
America is a cutter fitter the boss will
applied after the text collector had
collected we when didn't ask Alec Alec
so he replied that one or two days
before Eid so based on this the right
ruling is it should be given before the
Idul Fitri salah either in the morning
before they go for solid that's the best
or on the eve of it'll fit it or one two
or three days before Eid that's the rule